die werde ich muss vielleicht hallöchen
durch in münchen meine freunde und das
ist ein total schwule begrüßung
naja egal ich würde sagen wir haben
locker wie lange nicht mehr gespielt
locker zwei drei monate oder so ich habe
mich jetzt erst mal auf das neue konzept
konzentriert auf minecraft
aber ich habe diese lady echt kein
bisschen vermisst also das musste schon
so direkt ins gesicht sagen ich weiß
jetzt böse auf mich sein aber mit
bündeln egal so play ich würde sagen wir
schauen wir direkt an und zwar ich mal
bei facebook gepostet dass ich eine neue
idee hat für happy meals und die idee
war einfach dass ich zwar 15 minuten
aufnehmen aber nur die besten stellen
raus schneider und dann zusammen
hintereinander packe damit dass quasi
von 23 minuten video wird und davon dann
irgendwie seltener wird hochladen also
keine ahnung in der woche mal einen
happy meals video so drei minuten
könnt ihr mir geteilt haben in die
kommentare schreiben
ob ihr lieber einmal die woche von 15
minuten erzählen wollt wo ich wirklich
alles mache wo ihr alles geht oder ob
ich lieber so drei minuten videos machen
soll wo ich da nur so die besten sachen
sehen nur 70 sowie highlight sage ich
mal
also das können wir einfach mal die
kommentare schreibe ich habe die
komplette steuerung wieder vergessen
wird es noch mal ganz kurz machte hier
ich kann aber ganz kurz hier so dass
jetzt hier kann ich das überhaupt
irgendwie machen da ich weiß nicht ob
ich jetzt noch irgendwie meinem aussieht
oder so egal so ich würde sagen wir
fangen schon mal an
das war hüpfen z war festhalte im thalia
vergessen hier gibt auch okay ich soll
ja nicht reingehen optimierte stille
purple die wolke sich aus wie ein penis
hallo annett rosen skicross linesman was
never meant to cross
cool das will ich auch immer gern in der
schule machen also ich mache das ja auch
immer in der schule einfach über die
tische fan mit einem segway hier ist im
rhein ist es auch bei uns in der schule
so also ich glaube das ist sogar unsere
schule ist einfach so ein nachbau
müssten gleich einfach nur noch so ein
paar tote leichen seien von in welchen
schülern die die 20 jahre lang
nachsitzen mussten und dann ist es sogar
unsere schule so hier ist irgendwann
reaktor ich habe jetzt den knopf
gedrückt scheiße ich habe das gut ist
ich glaube tatsächlich notiert oder ich
werde einfach runter gekickt ropes hilfe
kannst hast du schon mal gespielt habe
das level ja das kann durchaus sein aber
ich hab's geschafft damals wegen diesem
blöden genau da hab ich mir manchmal
hätte mein bein gebrochen
gleich kommt so ein blöder dino nein
nicht der ein anderer und zwar der mich
immer getötet das war voll blöd guckt da
jetzt kommen andino vor dem muss ich
jetzt gleich weglaufen glaube ich oder
irgendwie so und jetzt muss ich einfach
weiterfahren weil das sonst den ganzen
einzelteile ist das schön oh gott baku
so nah kommt nämlich durch irgendeinen
dino und dann muss sich vor dem wieder
wegfahren jetzt irgendwer da kommt er ja
und da bin ich gestorben
das war nicht so gut aber das schaffe
ich jetzt auf jeden fall weitere restart
level war das glaube ich ist es okay gut
los geht's jetzt schaffen wir das mädel
spots also ok festival so jetzt können
wir schon ein bisschen schneller
vorgehen also ich weiß schon wo es lang
geht braucht ihr euch das alles ja nicht
zeigen dass ich darüber ob man kann da
also ich kann einfach mal ein bisschen
herum hüpfen ja ihr comeback und spielte
den beat yo-yo ma oder wider
ich steck fest doch nicht okay das war
ein bisschen schnell alter betreibt ein
bisschen schnell weitergeht sagt und
jetzt fliege ich wieder so aufbauen dass
ich mir gleich als bräche doch nicht
schön ich bin noch ganz freut mich jetzt
eine wippe da ist ein dinosaurier der
neun kinder hat er es nicht tut der hat
einfach nur ein bisschen viel ketchup
gegessen so du wirst jetzt erstmal
getötet und entsorgt
wir fahren jetzt aber erst mal weiter so
und jetzt kommen nämlich gleich hier die
schönen babys das ging schneller als wir
diese dieses ding so jetzt ganz schnell
wieder zurück und gleich sind wir in
deren höhle und da unten habe ich
nämlich letzte mal verklagt so jetzt bin
ich in der höhle
so muss sich ganz ganz vorsichtig und
langsam bin ich im wasser und hier bin
ich irgendwo vergraben verkackt ich weiß
nicht mehr genau wo irgendwo hier muss
auch schauen ob ich das schaffe ist das
paradies anscheinend manchmal lernt hier
ja ich muss erst wieder hochkommen ich
muss erstmal überhaupt da irgendwo
hinkommen
checkt gajic holt ok ok just am step be
wie crêpes ich denke nein
und jetzt ab die ohne gott ach du
scheiße und jetzt ob die armee und ab
dafür und ab der fisch und jetzt hier
und so und mal so macht da sind immer
noch vorne so
und ab und ab somit auch mit space
konnte ich nehme c oder mit z da wird
mit space kann ich dir gefällt jetzt was
ich hier so an ich hab das dann kommt
das doch nicht so schwer jetzt hat ja
auch lange kommen ich nehme mich da ich
bin immer nah dran
ich muss ja irgendwie nach vorne erhält
detailwissen krank es ist einmal richtig
geil war das wird noch mal machen so
moment wir fangen noch mal von vorne an
so dass das letzte mal als ich will ja
nicht komplett derzeit jetzt mit einem
level verteidigt aber das erste mal dass
wir da anfangen
viele leute sagen ja immer lokal du
sollst den mehr zeit lassen
levels jede level sind machbar und das
schaffst sogar du also lass dir bitte
ein wenig mehr zeit sagen ja immer
manche leute und das möchte ich nun mal
machen so
okay gut drückt mir den schalter jetzt
geht dieser reaktor als mini me you
dance nämlich angesagt los geht's und es
geht gut und besitzt die wollen mich
verarschen oder ok meine damen und
herren gerade es mir so stilvoll happy
meals abgestürzt deswegen bin ich jetzt
einfach hier im user level browser habt
ihr schon mal angefangen weil ich das
machen wollte und ich würde sagen jetzt
machen direkt weiter es ist mir wirklich
einfach so einfach so abgestürzt okay
gut das ist für teenager scott okay also
gott bin natürlich ist klar wir nehmen
wieder man mit sohn
ok ich glaube ich sollte den alten oper
nehmen wenn ja ist jetzt kein problem
ich mach da hatte ich schaffe das mit
dem rover ok anscheinend doch nicht
dann nehme ich auf jeden fall den der
doch noch ach so geht gar nichts mehr
schön kann mit den alten weniger mit der
alten funktionieren und die mit dem
wurst lang es wieder glauben
die cola verlor so klaus biersack 8 die
kann springen mit dem ding dort weiter
kommen wir drehen uns einfach so
rückwärts wtf
ok cool tolles level auf jeden fall muss
ich sagen viele sehr schön so was gut
zusammen so sind mega jump
das heißt wir müssen den pokal mitnehmen
das ist dieser eine ihr glaube ich doch
nicht hey das ist eine mutter mit ihrem
kind und hey das gab ein kind gestorben
da kennt wie gc hat mir geht's gut und
die ihr soll man war ja mir auch mama
was ist das darum urlaub zu machen was
ist das da oben vögel auf jeden fall für
moment ach so ich muss hier können wir
wenigstens hier noch umbringen wartet so
kind auch als kind opfer das ist scheiße
so bestimmen ist dieser fritzi okay so
nein ich bin so ein blödmann
so ist es schwieriger als man denkt man
denkt so ja der kann sich einfach genau
so geht's okay so bewegt man sich
übrigens voran mit dem ding wenn das
jetzt irgendwie funktionieren würde
okay gut funktioniert verdammt ich
[Musik]
dachte dass er eine richtige weg gewesen
ok anscheinend müssen wir doch in diese
richtung in diese richtung gott nein
auftakt in diese richtung kann
vielleicht war dahin gehen wo ich hin
will
diese richtung nein
püttmann es ist doch weil es nicht so
schwer
doch das schafft das doch schon mal ganz
gut ich bin gott wenn ich jetzt dadurch
schaffe haye hatte ich muss vielleicht
so ja ja ja
arschloch moment ja letztlich schaffe
dann arbeitet wird er war schon mal gut
der wird nicht klappen ich kann es ja
mal scheiße ich hab einen helm verloren
das geht natürlich gar nicht klar das
muss natürlich sofort auf wenn ihr also
das level war irgendwie doof crashs taff
staff genau da gehöre ich hin
aber ich weiß gar nicht was soll ich
überhaupt hin da bin ich weg aus dem
pilz hatte eventuell auch cool ich kann
er steuern früchte rohstoff was ist noch
so ein paar sachen ok cool und ich hätte
gern noch mal früchte
hey das war mein alter das man alles
klappt gibt mein klo zurück ach du
scheiße das hat jetzt gerade ein
bisschen
und jetzt wird's richtig haken genau
jetzt alter liegt ein bisschen viel
abfall
naja ok gut schönes level hat sehr viel
spaß gemacht muss ich sagen
kenny dürfte norbert frie hat eine sehr
gute bewertung
ich bin mir wieder mit vater und kind
und es ist ein problem
ok jetzt gehts ja okay das schaffen wir
natürlich kenne wird sich jetzt nicht so
schwer aus ihr geht es gut
yao ming ist bestens das ist natürlich
das wichtigste der vater klammert sich
erst mal so ein ding und fabriziert
damit irgendwelche dinge die ok ich
glaube wir brauchen irgendwie diesen
typen das wäre schon ganz vorteilhaft
weil ich damit erstmal im boden stecken
stecken fest feststecken
hallo erzählen dass ich statt im boden
ein low wolfgang wir machen hat jetzt
kann man diesen homo ehen im alltag
leider niemals springen ja toll change
charakter dann nehme ich hier den rookie
mit dem mittel mit dem rookie
funktioniert hat nie naja dann ist das
auch irgendwie blöd so hart es käufer
genau was für mich die wollen nicht dass
das mache doch das funktioniert jetzt
das funktioniert jetzt wenn ich das
jetzt sagen es funktioniert
ok dann sei es halt noch mal wenn ich
das jetzt sagen okay dann halt noch mal
wenn ich das jetzt sage dann
funktioniert ist auf jeden fall dass
hier
[Musik]
ich bin so krass ist das erste level war
sie hat geschafft habe super von alle
zahlen wahrscheinlich sogar in deutscher
so dass du das letzte level sein was ich
heute mache und das wäre jetzt nicht bei
dem dritten mal funktioniert okay gut
wir schaffen das
ich hab's geschafft kommentiert schaffen
was mit 4,93 sekunden
meine damen und herren das war es auch
schon wieder mit happy meals schreibt
mir wie schon gesagt in die kommentare
ob ich das vielleicht zu machen soll
dass sich kürzere petition mache wo ich
dann einfach nur die highlights frau
schneide
er bricht sich erst mal noch ein abend
das ist natürlich sehr schön und dann
will ich sagen sie muss man jetzt mal
tschüss wie man bewerte nicht vergessen
also oben links ist die anmerkung was
ihr machen könnte mich glücklich zu
machen stößt aber jetzt soll